another guy that's out there that you
have at number three
on your worst number four quarterbacks
is it four who's he behind what are your
first three you know
i got oh that's right wilson lawrence
jones and then mom jones that's right
number four i misspoke they know who we
make number four still a surprise
because it's the head of fields and
lands yeah kellen monde he had his pro
day workout at texas a m on
tuesday here's mond after his workout
personally i don't mind being underrated
because
at the end of the day you know
especially when you get to the league
you're always going to have to depend on
yourself
and also the people around you to
succeed um you know uh you know a lot of
guys and you know with me um you know
i've been through a lot of adversity
before the season if you know if
somebody went to the media and told you
you know kell and mon you know loses his
number one receiver from um the year
before and loses uh you know his three
other top receivers um at the time um
you know would he have his best season
go nine and one um
and you know pretty much have his best
season you know i'm pretty sure 100 100
of people would have told me no um so
um i don't mind being underrated because
you know the chips are gonna fall um you
know where everything and uh where it
may and um
you know so i just i just uh try to
operate uh be even kill and you know
everything will um happen not the best
time for me
he specifically mentioned yesterday
talking with the steelers and the bears
of course all teams can talk to as many
of the candidates as they want up to i
think it's five one hour sessions
on zoom
so that doesn't have the significance as
a visit would have but clearly the
steelers and the bears thinking about
2022 quarterback position they're one of
the teams that you know they know who
they have this year they don't know who
they're going to have next year and mond
in chicago or pittsburgh would be
learning behind someone else and sitting
for a year but you know chris what where
do you think his realistic
ceiling is
despite what you think of him and you
would have him maybe even as high as a
top 10 pick where do you really think
he's going to end up what's the highest
he could hope for i think that the the
thing i look at more than anything would
be
you know maybe he could be a guy that
ends up getting drafted late in the
first round with a team like i know
bruce arians made a comment about maybe
the quarter they would think about
drafting a quarterback at 32 right to me
that would be kellen mon that would be
that guy right there you know and and
really the bears steelers i would think
there's a lot of thoughts there of you
know second round pick two you know but
i think ultimately yeah it's going to be
the second round is what it sounds like
yeah i don't agree with that i don't i
think this guy's got big time talent and
i think he's got big time talent in the
pocket to make all the throws quick
release doesn't need space around him
can make unreal throws when the pocket's
collapsing all of those type of things
but yeah i think ultimately nfl teams
are going to take this guy
anywhere between
let's say 25 and 45 mike i think that's
about the general range where kelanman
will go in the draft
and bruce aarons did mention the
possibility of taking a quarterback at
number 32
you know another possibility when you're
holding that last spot in round one is
to trade out with a team
who's in round two
who didn't get a quarterback in round
one right to swoop back in that's a
valuable spot we've seen that happen
with teddy bridgewater it happened with
lamar jackson trading back to 32 getting
the five-year contract with the
quarterback and you avoid the dak
prescott four-year
conundrum and
who knows what you can pick up by way of
an extra draft pick or two by sliding
out of that spot and going into round
two that that's right you know i mean
you think that the bucks at 32 with the
calvin monde okay maybe that could be a
possibility you know i think that could
be a great situation for vermont to be
there for a year
learn from a brady and everything else
and then take over if brady does retire
you know i also look at like hey the
jacksonville jaguars they're i mean not
the jacksonville jaguars excuse me the
atlanta falcons sitting there at number
36 in the second round if they decided
maybe they don't go trey lance at four
which a lot of people have them rumored
to do
you know kellen mon to me i think would
be the guy a guy that would that would
fancy their way of play
arthur smith what he wants to do look at
here's kevin mann
he's similar to ryan tannehill and the
way he just played in the tennessee
titans offense that i've gotten this job
for for what i did there i mean that
that to me is another thought that has
crossed my mind too that atlanta at the
top of the second maybe they even traded
up to the late first something around
that area would make sense and i think
that's ultimately where i see kelanman
kind of falling to
and you can really pick up if you're the
bucks you can really pick up some future
assets and maybe some present assets by
sliding back if the opportunity comes to
you it's a valuable valuable pick to
have that 30-second spot if there is a
quarterback still lingering right who
has slid past all the others and is
there on the board he could end up being
number six though of the first round
quarterbacks assuming all the others end
up going in round one it's going to be a
fun draft from the standpoint of
quarterbacks as i i think what's
happening
is and
one of my pet peeves about the draft is
on draft night no one ever is going to
point out you know what there's a pretty
good chance this guy's a bust every pick
every first round pick there's a pretty
good chance he's never going to be very
good but in recent years the success
rate for quarterbacks chris has gone up
that the offenses are adapting to what
the guys did in college that caused the
teams to fall in love with them in the
first place
so the idea of possibly six first-round
quarterbacks and it not being like 83
where for every dan marino there's a
tony eason for every jim kelly there's a
todd black ledge
you could get six first rounders and
they could all end up being pretty damn
good quarterback definitely what and
there's more flexibility of the way
these guys play so there's more
flexibility too within these new teams
to find ways that they can still be
successful with these guys and you know
like we've talked about so many times
too mike teams have just realized wait
if i'm gonna drop this guy here
my name is attached to this like i need
to make this work so the smart ones have
done a great job and and invested in
supporting that top 10 quarterback or
whatever it may be you know so yes i
mean
you're i mean you're right there's not a
lot of busts that you think about over
the last few years i mean you know right
now i mean josh rosen i guess kind of
fits that mold you know we have like the
christian ponders and and dwayne haskins
so far to this point jake locker from
the titans i know i'm missing some other
ones 2011 2000 i i think the the worm
turned at some point in the last decade
where the success rate went up 2011 was
a disaster it was jake locker at eight
blaine gabbard at 10.
both afc south teams taking those guys
when jj watt was still on the board
right who those afc south teams had to
deal with for the next decade and then
christian ponder at 12. that was the
year without free agency before the
draft that was the year where teams got
extra desperate in round one and and
there was that 8 10 12 bust bust bust
but at some point since then
it shifted
at some point since then
teams realized if we're going to take
this guy we got to do everything in our
power to make this guy successful
and we've seen the rate of success go up
some point between 2011 and
2017-ish i have to go back at every
draft class and look but i feel like the
success rate has gotten higher in recent
years and not that they're going to go
six for six this year if there are six
first round quarterbacks but it just
feels like
you're knocking and it's i feel like
teams are drafting fewer
projects in round one right
if you can't if you can't get a
quarterback who can come in and play
right away this year we'll wait till
next year and we'll get a quarterback
who can come and play then because you
know a lot of these teams with
quarterback needs already have veterans
who can play yeah so i think that's one
of the reasons as well you don't have as
much of a role of the dice at
quarterback as you used to have no no
definitely not the quarterbacks too i
think are you know more well schooled
and ready to play in the nfl than ever
before but listen at the end of the day
that's why i got lance and fields at
five and six you know because i do think
there's project there's issues there you
know to me it's not a slam dunk i there
is as great as some of their high-end
talent is there is a little bit of a bus
factor for me with those guys and that's
why i got them there because there's
some issues with their throwing and
things like that that you know i just
don't think are as top-notch or as
consistent as as the top four four guys
i got them on my board at least
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports